Captivating new characters, another awesome
mix tape, and a generous helping of heart
are just some of the things waiting for you
in the bundle of fun that is Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 2.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Just before I kick off my review proper, I
want to let you know I'm running a Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 2 giveaway on all my new
Guardians 2 videos.
For a chance to win, make sure you're subscribed
and leave a comment about the movie on this
video.
I'll have full details of the prizes at the
end of my review!
Ok, as I mentioned before, as well as our
team of returning heroes, we also get a bunch
of new characters and actors, who I really
enjoyed seeing in the movie.
As the insect-like alien, Mantis, Pom Klementieff
is a simply perfect addition to this universe,
and gives a charmingly subtle performance
that really highlights her character's innocence,
good nature, and humour, and her scenes with
Drax, in particular, are an utter joy.
Elizabeth Debicki, who you'll have seen in
The Man From UNCLE and alongside Tom Hiddleston
in the TV series The Night Manager, gives
a superbly stately and condescending turn
which fits her character wonderfully as she
plays Ayesha, the High Priestess of the ever-so-arrogant
alien race, the Sovereign.
And Kurt Russell is just fantastic as Ego
in all his forms, managing to make this crazy
character believable, and also establishing
a great on-screen rapport with Chris Pratt's
Star-Lord.
Just like the first film, there's plenty of
irreverent humour in Vol. 2, a lot of which
lands very well, and there's a good chunk
of fun and thrilling action too, however this
time, there's also more emotional weight given
to the Guardians' story, with an emphasis
placed on family, whether that's the family
you were born into or the people you meet
along the way.
And having got to know his main cast and their
characters well over the course of filming
the first movie, it feels like writer-director
James Gunn has honed this script so it pretty
much plays to each actor's particular strengths.
The fact that Drax has a love of the literal
as well as about as much tact as a ton of
bricks means that Dave Bautista gets a mass
of marvellously funny lines, which he nails
thanks to his great comic timing and delightfully
deadpan delivery.
And then there's that hilariously hearty laugh
Bautista does as Drax which never fails to
put a smile on my face and you'll hear plenty
of throughout the film.
As Peter Quill, aka Star-Lord, Chris Pratt
showcases a range of humour, action, and more
heartfelt, dramatic moments.
While Zoe Saldana and Karen Gillan get some
cool action and the chance to peel back the
layers of Gamora and Nebula's backstory.
And Michael Rooker certainly makes the most
of the increased screen time Yondu gets this
time around, adding extra depth to his character.
As for Baby Groot, he's a mix of ultra-cute
adorableness and a seething stack of rage,
and the VFX guys have done superb job injecting
this tiny tree creature with a real sense
of soul and personality.
I also really like Bradley Cooper's Rocket,
who gets a nice emotional arc this time too.
Yes, there were odd moments of his humour
that didn't work for me, but he does still
get lots of great moments and I love Rocket
in all his fast-talking, sass-mouthed glory.
As was the case with the first movie, the
soundtrack for Vol. 2 is a gorgeous mix that
I'm looking forward to listening to again
and again.
And as far as the movie's concerned, each
track gels beautifully with the scene it's
in, taking the on-screen visuals to another
level.
Speaking of visuals taken to new heights,
the production design for this movie is out
of this world!
From the Sovereign's planet, which is all
Art Deco-style lavishness to Ego's home, which
perfectly reflects who his character is, the
work of the movie's art, design, and VFX teams
really shines.
And, as you'd expect from a movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, there are post-credits
scenes, five to be precise, so it's definitely
worth sticking around until the very end of
the film.
Plus, there are also plenty of easter eggs
and references in the movie too.
And I'll be making videos about those various
post-credits scenes and their significance
in the MCU as well as the movie's easter eggs
very shortly.
To sum up: Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 is
entertainment of cosmic proportions, or to
put it another way, it was a pleasure to watch.
Writer-director James Gunn blends plentiful
laughs with an emotional kick in the gut and
a galaxy of scene-stealing performances from
cast old and new.
And I cannot wait to see what Gunn has up
his sleeve for Vol. 3!
But in the meantime, I'm looking forward to
watching Vol. 2 again!
Now, what are you looking forward to about
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2?
And who are your favourite characters in the
Guardians movies?
Don't forget to comment and subscribe for
a chance to win one of several Guardians prizes.
I've got two awesome hardback books from DK,
Guardians of the Galaxy: The Ultimate Guide
to the Cosmic Outlaws, which takes an in-depth
look at iconic characters, issues and storylines
from the comics.
And I've also got a selection of three very
cool Guardians Funko Pop vinyl figures.
The giveaway will run for two to three weeks
on all my Guardians Vol. 2 videos and I'll
announce the winners on a new video after
that.
So, make sure you hit the bell to turn on
notifications so you stay up-to-date with
all my new videos.
And if you enjoyed this video, do hit that
thumbs-up button and check out more of my
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 and Marvel
videos right here!
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!